and cut
kenny and max
[Laughter]
my students quote me all the time
have one of the hottest up-and-comers in
nashville who studied with us and is in
our movie played the dad in our movie
and he says that every time he goes on
stage
he says i'm take he told me this the
other day he says i carry your bag of
tools with me every time i go on stage
that's a great compliment
okay simmer down
here everybody never step down now sit
down
we are rolling
we have speed
we have a mark
and action
of course you resent it
but you should know there's a simple way
to silence all these unjust criticisms
if you were just to produce some
accounts and why should i
why should i submit
to the bullying of the diocesans offices
why should i open up private files so
you can appease your obstreperous
archdeacon
who is currently browbeating you into
taking an undignified and undefined
stance
and if i do give into this request i
will be taking a serious
i understand your anger
but you should know
and i you know i see your point of view
but stephen you've got to listen to me
what i'm about to tell you
[Music]
it's okay can i review my my script
really quickly sure don't get up we'll
bring it to you
i just want to review this it's all
right
geez it's hard to find good
help see karen can you feel the love you
feel the love here all we have is love
see don't screw up again david
he knows i'm just kidding
focus guys take your time max obviously
forgot the number one lesson
have a break off
also it is ridiculously warm in here you
are wearing this well you're wearing a
wool jacket what the heck
you have a hole in your armpit or
something you don't want us to see your
shirt or what
go back house
[Laughter]
okay give them a minute guys
we're rolling
take your own action
of course you resent it
but you should know there's a simple way
to silence all these unjust criticisms
if you were just to produce some
accounts then why should i
why should i
submit to the bullying of the diocesan
offices
why do i need to produce files
private files just so you can appease
your archdeacon who is currently
browbeating you into taking an
undignified and undefined stance
and if i were to give in
i would be taking the most dangerous
precedent
now believe me the
the cannons will have my back up the
hilt in asserting the dean and chapter's
ability to withstand
any
any interference from the archdeacon
or any of his ordering of the
cathedral's affairs
i understand your anger and i see your
point of view
but stephen
please i beg of you please listen
carefully to what i'm about to say i
myself don't see any
deliberate issue
but
it should be a fact that anyone even
someone as financially enjoyed as you
can
commit a mistake that proves expensive
if there is indeed and made a mistake
somewhere along the line please tell me
right now so i could give you my full
support in sorting out all these
consequences
i can understand whether it be
circumstances where
talking to the cannons wouldn't be in
your best
favor but
please know that i'm on your side with
this
how extremely kind of you
but i am in no need of a confessor
i should also warn you that if you
continue to persist
in your refusal to cooperate with me
i shall feel obliged to make a
visitation then make it
i hope you enjoy the moment when i
present you with immaculate accounts
yeah that's a very irresponsible
attitude for seeing your churchmen to
adopt
shouldn't you be thinking of ways you
could best avoid no force shouldn't you
i don't understand this this lust this
lust to play the grand inquisitor of the
chapter's house is more than a little
distasteful
you are only supposed to go around and
be everybody's fathering god
not prying into the cathedral's affairs
like some fraud squad detective now let
me repeat
everything
is fine
i have control of everything
and the appeal is on course so why don't
you go back to your little job of
playing the good bishop and leave me in
peace to play the good dean because i
know from past experience that the role
of good dean is one that you sometimes
have great trouble says how dare you how
dare you and since you insist on a spade
being a spade i hardly think you're in
the right to complain when i follow your
example
so stephen
let's just have a conversation
in a calm civilized and dare i say
christian manner
let's try to get a hold of ourselves
i
don't want to have a visitation
but i think that is a lie you've been
longing for years to make a visitation
so you can run my thrace my face through
the mud
and don't think i don't know why
steve you haven't forgiven me have you
you haven't forgot that i may have made
a pass at your wife
and the problem is your wife didn't seem
too upset about it are you bloody liar
you bloody liar she was never interested
in you she fought you off
i know she did not you went hard for a
long time she didn't fight at all
it's a good thing i didn't have a drink
oh you always have too much to drink i
mean the only reason you spend your
entire damn life
committing adultery is because you're
always too honest
with me
righteous hypocritical
righteous and hypocritical
about telling the truth
it's not
the truth
i i speak the truth when i tell you you
are self-righteous and hypocritical how
dare you accuse me of immorality when
you are the one who went to bed last
night with harriet march and don't
pretend you don't know what i'm talking
about
and don't act like i will keep quiet for
the good of the church either
in
fact in fact go ahead make that
visitation
because if you do i will go up to
harriet's highest friends in london and
tell them about the affair
and then the news of the world will be
on your doorstep quicker than you can
draw a breath to lie about your
innocence there wasn't an affair that's
not what harriet had to say she's lying
i don't trust you and i don't believe
you and neither will the news of the
world well that's it
you just convinced me without a shadow
of doubt that you are utterly unfit to
be the dean of a great cathedral i will
force you out of starbridge even if it's
the very last thing i ever do
the minute you you got past that hump
yeah you know that little hurdle
it really started rocking
and this is why
i've never had an actor in 30 years of
coaching get on a set for the first time
and be uncomfortable
the chances of you getting a roll like
this at the stages that most of you are
are 10 million to one
so if you can do this here and produce
as well as you did
five lines eight lines on a shonda rhyme
show
who cares
you'll go in and kick ass yeah you'll
get the job done you'd do really well
and you'll get you know i just had one
of my actors just guest starred
on on
chicago med and now
he's guest starring on
on
powerbook four
so
this works guys this process works
you don't have to
get your book of verbs
you you don't have to dissect the script
you don't have time for it you just
don't have time
you know
you get a call on friday
for an audition on friday morning you
get a call back friday afternoon
you're on the set monday morning
when you do back story when do you do
research you don't have time
five things to look at on every script
five things real simple who
what where
when why
done
here's a question for you guys
if
you are in scenes four five and six
scenes 31 32 and 33
and scenes 89 91 and 92. do you have to
read the whole script
no
why
that's information you don't need it's
not your story it's not your story
you're concerned with the scenes you're
in
i love when harvey keitel gave dinero
the uh
kennedy awards center award
he was up there and he looked up at
bobby and he says bobby i want to thank
you for teaching the most important
thing about memorization
my line my line my line [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] my line my line
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] my line my
line okay it's not that simple of course
but there's no reason for you to know
what's going on in the story if you're
not involved in part of that story
why
what's the first thing about
screenwriting the first rule about
screening
writing is if it doesn't add to the
story take it out of the screenplay
you see it all the time in movies
they'll go from one sequence to another
you sort of what
but then you think back and think oh it
didn't matter
it doesn't matter
if it doesn't add to the story it
doesn't matter if what you're going to
read about is only going to clutter your
brain with
excess matter
why do we need to know it we don't
how long was a guy in germany
i don't care
i don't care i'm not in that scene
i don't care if he you know spent his
life there
okay it's a ball buster guys and i i
doff my hat you know and but this is why
we're here
this is why all the material we have is
original material and i purposely pull
material that's going to be hard for you
that's going to take you out of your
comfort zone
that's going to make you break down
that's going to keep you from smiling
all the time you're not my only smiler
anymore
no no no the smiling bellado smiling in
that sequence was wonderful but you
remember used to do that a lot i have a
beautiful gal in a wednesday morning who
does the same thing not anymore she did
six months ago she smiled through
everything
i could give her a funeral sequence
she'd be smiling
you know she didn't want me to see what
was going on inside of her
well you have to be willing to do that
you have to be willing to show me
you know you guys were furious with each
other
and it wasn't about the church and it
wasn't about money it was about who whom
it was personal it was personal
it was personal
and it became very personal for both of
you in the sequence and because it was
personal it became visceral for me
okay
yeah
don't you cry make me cry
okay we good in the booth yeah yeah
we're good that was really great guys
okay mr abner you've got the con
try to hold for a few seconds of sound
holding for sound
and motorcycles
hey that's frontier airlines tv oh sorry
it's both oh yeah
spirited frontier
i think we're clear now
okay take your time guys focus a minute
we're rolling
or take your own action
of course you're it
but you should know there is an easy way
to silence all these unjust criticisms
if you were to produce some accounts
then why should i
why should i
submit to the bullying of the diocesan's
offices
why should i open up private files so
that you can appease your obstreperous
archdeacon who is currently browbeating
you into taking an undignified and
undefined stance
and if i were to give in to this request
i'd be setting the most dangerous
precedent
now i assure you
the canons have my back to the hilt in
asserting the dean and chapter's ability
to withstand
any interference from the archdeacon and
the ordering of the cathedral's affairs
i understand your anger
and i see your point of view but stephen
i beg of you please listen very
carefully to what i'm about to say
i personally don't see any deliberate
wrongdoing
but it is a fact that anyone even
someone as financially a joy as you can
commit a mistake that proves expensive
if there
really has been a mistake made somewhere
along the line please tell me now so
that i could back you completely
but
i also can understand that there are
these circumstances
that speaking to the cannons wouldn't be
in your favor
and i'd be failing you as your bishop if
i didn't at least give you the chance to
confide in me
well how extremely kind of you but i am
in no need of a confessor i should also
warn you that if you persist in your
refusal to cooperate with me i
shall feel obliged to make visitation
then make it
and i hope you enjoy what you find when
i present you immaculate accounts
that's a very irresponsible attitude for
seeing your churchmen to adopt shouldn't
you be thinking of ways to best avoid
unfortunately
you
listen to yourself
this lust to become this grand
inquisitor of the chapter's house is
more than a little sickening
your job is to go around being
everybody's father and god not prying
into the cathedrals cathedral's affairs
like some
mob squad detective
now listen to me when i tell you
everything is fine
i have everything under control
the appeal is on course so why don't you
do me a favor and go back to your job
and play the good little bishop
and leave me in peace to play the good
dean
because i know from past experience that
the role of a good dean is one that you
sometimes have great trouble sustaining
oh how dare you how
dare you since you insist on calling a
spade a spade i hardly think you're in
the right to complain when i follow your
example
so stephen let's get a grip on ourselves
and try to have a conversation in a calm
civilized and dare i say christian
manner i'll start by offering some
information that is true and which i
hope you all accept as a peace offering
signifying my good intentions
i don't want to have a visitation
and i think it'd be infinitely better
for the church it is a lie
you have been longing for years to make
a visitation here so you could rub my
face in the mud and don't think i don't
know why
you still haven't forgiven me steve you
haven't forgotten that i may have made a
pass at your wife
and you haven't forgotten that she
wasn't as upset
as she should have been you bloody liar
you bloody liar she was never interested
in you she fought you off i know she
thought you would not fight that hard
and for a while she did not fight at all
good thing i didn't have too much to
drink oh you always have so much to
drink the only reason why you don't
spend your entire damn life committing
adultery is because you're always too
bloody sought after
self-righteous hypocritical so
self-righteous
i am speaking the truth when i call you
self-righteous and hypocritical
now how dare you accuse me
of immorality when you just last night
were in bed with harriet march
wait no
don't act like you don't know what i'm
talking about
and don't think for once i will keep
silence for the good of the church
in fact if you go through with this
visitation
i shall reach out to harriet's highest
friends in london and tell them about
the affair and then the news of the
world will be on your doorstep quicker
than you can come up with a lie about
your innocence but there wasn't any
affair that's not what harry had to say
but she's lying
all good for you
because i don't trust you
and neither will the news of the world
that's it
you just convinced me without a shadow
of doubt that you are utterly unfit to
be the dean of a great cathedral i will
force you out of starbridge even if it's
the very last thing i ever do
and cut there we go
nice
nice nice nice
solid see that's that's
that's some of the best most relaxed
unaffected work that you've ever done
do you feel it yeah do you feel it
you've done it
you've got to feel it you've got to feel
it i can't make you feel it i can't get
you to
that place
get mad at me
it's up to you
uh
we could do uh rochelle and kai but then
genie has to work back to back and i
don't know that jeannie wants to do
we should take a that
okay
break time
coffee time break time water time
candy time